pas de temps la bousculade baroin
je ne sais pas parce que la terre est
ronde qui posé sur mes pieds
moi aussi je veux la voir la mariée je
suis de cette assiette puis
s'assoupissent ans et malgré fait pas de
bruit j'écoute la musique ils sont payés
du veto vent c'est dommage quel grand
paravent fins un petit peu embêté xhasa
jeu convaincant atteindrait tout enfin
faut pas demander le pérou attention
attention vis calendal la poupée
regardez-moi saga des mois sa ville
natale et vive la mariée en janvier son
mot qui leur vient pas de sentir posé
contre son bras une petite main aussi
légère pourvu qu'ils aient la bonne
manière pour la conduire comme une amie
tout là bas jusqu'au bout de la vie pour
un peu j'irai lui parler je dirais juste
que tu as la chance de posséder atteint
13 heures fais attention joue pas en
faire quand c'est dans les mecs ça vous
passez il suffit de l'arrière pour que
ça casse
regarde là avec son voile blanc c'est
comme un ange tant qu'elle est belle
seulement un ange luxe aadl ça peut
facilement tout le corps tâche de la
tenir contre ton coeur et pays
c'est le fait une jolie musique comme
elle trouvera sa magnifique
et dans les rapports mais coûtait rien
mais qu'est ce que j'ai racontée je suis
pas le père du marié vaut mieux
s'écarter et faire ma place je veux
saluer c'est la joie qui passe vive la
belle et vive la barrière
tout le monde est parti c'est fini moi
je me demande avec envie
c'est donc kg ont tous montrent tous les
badauds qui a une fille qui m'a trouvé
bon comme a voulu que notre amour soit
pas une passade d'un jour je suis là
devant cette grande église a répété
toutes mes bêtises comme si le bon dieu
dans sa maison il pouvait entendre
raison puis m'envoyer une demoiselle
avec un voile tout en dentelle un voile
ciblant si beau avoir qui couvrirait
tout le côté noir ou ce que mon coeur
fait sentinelle pourtant pas que ça
arrivera
les gars comme nous on est des gars pour
applaudir les réussites à part ceux qui
doit profiter bas il ya ceux qui doivent
se contenter de pousser des bravos la
suite
alors comme je crois que c'est mon cas
et connaught remporta son bras la femme
que j'aurai des cirés 61.8 chialer quand
il l'écrivait vive la belle et vive la
belle